can you I know welcome to this video
playing smoothie girl from Finland
that's a new one workout right okay
let's see probably d3 now funky position
already d 6 is a pretty decent replied
you are formed it's a bit unconventional
it yeah I mean every g3 this is pretty
much asking for for this kind of thing
and it is usually um quite good this is
this kind of attack it's not something
like a dicey non-solid kind of thing
it's usually it's just just usually good
here Bishop takes us g5 so what's going
on here um I take on g3 I cannot quickly
probably a ticket first and then think
about it now here 456 I have to develop
castles it's not something I actually
expected now you can still catch me in
this position let's see when it's it's
pretty pretty wacky this in this
situation with hmm between you 144 the
position is very strange which is
usually not favorable for me and tend to
be better in somewhat more conventional
situations now yeah that seems to be
okay for white him
seems to be ok as weird and it looks not
quite sure bishop t5 might be might be a
move some kind of gambling that this
doesn't get plate I'm not really sure
what I'm doing against it I could have
taken on g3 I think and create forward
did this really look digitally wrong to
me so I didn't do it yeah probably have
to do this
f6 says some tech tech oh yeah bishop
have six loops oops oops oops yeah that
didn't go too well probably maybe d 5
cancels if she or he just canceled yeah
I know now a miracle chess yeah let's
play miracle chess so Bishop g5 Bishop
g7 bishop Wow M Necker one let's take
this so publisher g7 route g8 no but
this looks this looks okay for me I'm
right or not in that ok for me let's get
the King out of this and now wide scale
position should be somewhat relevant
right Queen to e6 what
okay I don't want to trade Queens Queen
g4 was of course a move I wanted to play
but I did not want to trade Queens which
yeah why this kind of insisting to do
yeah I can take g3 here and doesn't it
certainly doesn't lead to all that much
mm-hmm then white maybe just moves the
Niten and then I'm in this wacky pin
wow what did what a weird game
the damn night would actually go to a
foyer 95-94 time morning or this one
they cannot take here because this this
is hanging what a weird game yeah loopy
one or something what am i overlooking
here avnet ciated and and why is this
literally equal I thought I should be
borne up I'm not I thought I was a porno
really oh my wouldn't be again and they
have 20 seconds on the clock which I
never realized I'm crazy-crazy never
notice that I'm down on the clock
yeah it needs the position is good now
check check check
now 15 seconds haha will be will be too
much of a problem probably
mmm six seconds in it I would I had up
okay I slipped this but ok he would have
one on time anyway or she loved young
[ __ ] fence on time yeah and this game
um why should never see move 15 or
something because the opening the debt
that looked kind of strange to be honest
so yeah but the engine doesn't see a
flattering for me that I was surprised i
think there i thought there should be
something that is even better than what
what the engine gives like 0.5 0.6 okay
degrees on this movement in my just
castled huh yeah it's amazing I wonder
about the stock fish depth ians doesn't
really calculate all that quickly for
some reason I don't know why Garrett
Thomas she'll Becky game such a wacky
position yeah it was funny yeah I mean
some things hit me by surprise here
especially the time situation I wasn't
short cancels ok yeah I mean that
actually makes quite some send them on
g6 young okay my original a problem was
I wanted to do this which is not wrong
you to Queenie 6 and that made me
ultimately play this move okay knight c6
already was very good for Boyd guarantee
i'd simply i did not actually see that I
was having time issues and I also didn't
see that was material which is
materially equal yeah okay what's I
could have taken the rook
Wow
undo what cha i'm a bit stunned here ha
ha yeah I have no explanation for that
had no idea no idea I don't know maybe I
was kind of giving up already on this
because of the time I mean the position
was was good at once for me the night is
just a lot stronger him so I snatched
the porn ok this useless chatter dies
because the time will decide the game I
simply also forgot about the time I only
when I had 20 seconds realized how bad
it is pretty pretty weird but yeah I'm
kind of surprised that the computer
doesn't find anything substantial here
like a like a flat win because this just
looks pretty awful for white I mean 0.6
or something is this ok of course but I
really felt like this should be there
should be more available doesn't seem to
be the case though it wants to play
knight c6 am NOT bishop d6 yeah maybe I
mean Queenie one was that it was a
decent reply to be 56 and here it's not
clear that i need this probably this
this and this the castling quickly to
the to the Queen side is correct and
they're probably very murky and now it
gets to gets two evaluations that I
would have expected like 0 like one porn
from black or something but it wasn't
all that easy it's
okay guys thanks for watching